we want to show your top gusts mccarron
had the highest
gust for the day today at 37 miles per
hour north las vegas
mountains edge not too far behind also
in those mid 30s we told you yesterday
we'd see between
30 to 40 miles per hour we're kind of in
that range there to henderson
mountains edge at 32 centennial hills
also
32 for your top wind gusts temperatures
outside right now let's start off there
in the northwest part of the valley
centennial hills 60 for you that also
includes sky canyon 56 in summerlin 61
aliante
64 downtown the east side coming at 64
for sunrise manor
same for you in green valley whitney
ranch henderson 62
rhodes ranch at 61 mountains edge and
also southern highlands seven hills 61
as well 59
for prep 63 currently for boulder city
and
death valley coming in a very
comfortable 74 degrees at this hour
here's where it's not comfortable wind
show readings right now still
minus 11 in bismarck minus 3 in kc
oklahoma city minus two windshield
warnings still remain in these areas
here
in kansas city and also into oklahoma
as these temperatures are dropping like
a rock only three degrees
for dallas right now we're also tracking
this disturbance doesn't look like much
but the blue areas the core areas that
are blue indicate where we've got some
heavier amounts of snow coming down in
texas oklahoma
and this will track across the country
to the mid-atlantic states and provide
more snow
to them already we had just so much snow
already two feet in some spots from a
storm
just a few weeks ago our radar network
here picking up some snow flurries along
i-15 and the wasatch of course
near brian head good to see that but we
remain dry here and it will remain that
way also in the extended as well one
thing's for sure though your wind
will kick up again tomorrow again we'll
see those winds peak about 30
midday in the afternoon before they
decrease a little tomorrow night not
quite as strong as today
but still breezy for tomorrow 42 degrees
overnight for the low
clear and chilly north breezes that's
your temperature expecting overnight now
tomorrow 58 will be cooler but we're
going to retain some of those winds with
those gusts between 20 to 30 likes we
talked
about temperatures in the high 50s so
slightly below normal for this time of
the year
hear your neighborhoods high 50s across
the valley 57 aliante north las vegas
double five summerlin 56 centennial
hills mountains edge 57
60 the east side along with green valley
outside of town 56 fort prompt
laughlin at 65 degrees tomorrow
afternoon you're eight on the eight
sunshine for sure but more wind again
from another system that comes in this
weekend this won't be like what we had
this weekend
it will be windy and breezy and then
there's those 70s
next week here so i'm really excited
about that maybe even mid 70s by
wednesday next week
we'll take it thanks ted